[Music]
welcome back to off the record what are
we talking about whatever you want we
got touch back it's been a couple years
hey it's been a couple years i know
we've been separated for a long time but
i'm got the band back together yeah dude
we did the last time i saw you we did
like all guys day and now it's only all
guys days yeah i remember it's only one
guy
we uh we called my parents and asked
them how far you could stick a foreign
object up your your drugs remember that
yeah
what was the answer what was not very
far really yeah this was we talked about
like the early sex shock videos yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i said oh let's
just call my dad because this would be
funny
what does your dad do like
he's an anal prober he works at a sex
shop he's a hand surgeon slash you read
through a special snow knight just a
hand hand surgeon has he uh has that
ever come up in conversation again like
that one time not once not once so
that's how you know he always calls his
dad about anal stuff
hey dad can i stick uh this bottle up my
body he would be like you know
probably but why are you asking me
that probably is the best that's the
best part you troll them a lot you call
them a lot yeah we make we we make fun
of him a lot but he's a good sport i
actually called my dad uh two days ago
because you know the last jk news so i
have this story where i sell weed in
high school and i thought the most
genius place would be in my deodorant i
would uh push it out wow it smelled
pretty good cut off the top and then
take off the plastic stuff it inside and
i put the pack
back on so it looks like [ __ ] so it
looks like really weird you're just
using deodorant right and it covers the
smell and everything and it's the only
it's in my backpack and um a lot of like
first generation people don't even know
what deodorant is so i just thought it'd
be like for my dad
and then one day i'm sitting there
watching tv he comes and he's like
what's this with that with my ounce of
weed like what is this and i'm like
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna get my ass beat today
and he went to work and that's where i
ran away from home so i called them uh
they were talking about here
and i forgot who uh
told me well like what is your dad how
did your dad find out so i called him
two days ago oh you know you caught him
on the show live didn't you no he called
yeah i called them i'm like hey dad
what's funny is i did it for a vlog i
think i don't know how my dad just knows
me like really well but i call them and
i'm like hey daddy remember like when i
was like a freshman or sophomore in high
school and you found
my weed in my deodorant and then he was
like
are you filming this conversation
because he doesn't want it to be illegal
was like what the yeah and i'm like yes
and then he and he was like all right
he's like you want to know the truth i'm
like yeah he goes i forgot
he's like that's [ __ ] 20 years ago i
don't remember that
but he was like he was like i used to
just check your [ __ ] all the time
because they're doing all kinds of like
like illegal wrong things so he was just
saying that like throughout the day he
is just going through all my [ __ ] oh wow
like between my books like in my drawers
backpacks when my friends come did you
know that he was that doing i didn't
know did you have other stuff that you
would get in trouble for no because
others like because then that would be
interesting if he was like picking and
choosing what to like get you off he's
like all right so i can either go with
this or i could go with this which one
he's like the wii is a pretty big deal
yeah
he's like man
porno
i'll take this he's like ah all right
that one yeah best thing about having
worked with you for years is i know
exactly what your towel was that gave it
away to your death really what is it you
sounded like you're smiling the whole
time
probably
yeah yeah yeah yeah giggling
on the phone yeah so you're on the phone
but you know you're you got the vlog
camera and you're like you got your your
smile i know you are doing that i know
that's how he heard it yeah maybe that's
how he gave it away the first time
around i was like my deodorant stick
walking through
you're like hey
i love you
i love you i use it a lot i smell great
damn so he would go through your [ __ ]
all the time and you had no idea but you
think you think if taika was doing some
like funny [ __ ] you would be able to
know exactly what he was doing
i don't know
yet because right now when he play hide
and seek he's still like papa
you know he's like kind of dumb i just
mean like they're trolling that papa
how does he know
he's four now i'm sure you know when
he's about to do some like funny [ __ ]
like when he's about to be mischievous
oh exactly he's about to do it yeah
dapple got into his hiding place like it
was under the tv it was in this box and
he goes you want to play hide and seek
all right you start counting and
that who's just closed that's his way
that's his way of being like yo get the
[ __ ] off
giggling man he's like people don't know
the funny thing is once you find him
when he hides he hides in the same spot
i don't think you get the game you got
to pick a new spot because i know you're
spot now and he goes no no no you go
count and he goes
he's actually going in there to hang out
i didn't actually want to play the game
you would think that humans have evolved
so much that kids could play hide and
seek better yeah they don't get better
at it huh not really they don't never
you got to go through the same stages
i question evolution just based on how
bad kids are at hide and seek yeah
i don't know haven't learned wait so
when he gets older are you gonna also go
through his stuff as well to see if he's
hiding anything if he's a [ __ ] like
me there's gotta be a [ __ ] phase
though i have a track record so like
i got kicked out of two or three
elementary schools before like fifth
grade even you know so like my track
record hasn't been good so i think my
dad was just already like that looks
like a recipe for disaster lots of
parent-teacher conferences like got
suspended a couple times in junior high
so i think in high school he's like this
is when you're starting to get to that
like
like about to be 16 sometimes some
things can be tried as an adult age so i
think he was very like
let me see what the [ __ ] is going on
with this guy and then he stopped you
before you started robbing houses right
no
he was good at hiding that
he was hella good so what we find out is
that you're the ultimate hide-and-seek
player
he took all the genes in that one
that's duncan's not very good
see he doesn't have a record that's who
you get as a [ __ ] expert someone like
bart to talk about robin houses because
nobody caught him no that's true
how do you rob a house you just go
through the final window that's open
the ultimate strategy walk through the
open door
you try the door and see if it's open
and then if it is then you go away
friend that actually bought lock from
home depot to practice oh my god for me
we were i mean we weren't that
sophisticated we were just like scoping
out the house camping out casing it okay
cool everyone left go check out the
windows around the house backyard
anything open
uh this one's not good the next one
that's how that one serial killer on
netflix they're that killer in l.a
richard ramirez yeah do you i don't know
where i forgot his name but he would
just go through like open yeah the night
soccer you just go through open doors
and windows yeah that was it see he got
a good name by the way the night star is
a good one it is pretty good we should
start naming like killers like bad so
people don't want to be them exactly not
the nightstalker that's like the sickest
superhero name i've ever heard about
it's way better than shane
[Laughter]
it's like really easy to
get into a door though if you know how
because it's like the other day i called
the locksmith and because i was locked
out of my house and basically he comes
over like sticks this little thing into
my door hole takes a hammer like bashes
it once and then it pops open mike how
many houses have you broken into none
mike how many houses have you broken
into with your mind
[Laughter]
himself into it did he just teleport
through the glass
phase shifts dude yo mike does have
superpowers low-key no question anybody
i know
you just described mike perfectly lock
yourself out of the house i don't know i
mean like um
we were going to get sushi and uh we
were leaving in a rush or something yeah
and i was like running into russian so
like i was my girlfriend asked me like
well did you lock the do you have your
keys and i'm like yeah of course i have
the keys right they're having some hot
steamy sex and they're like the sushi
restaurant's gonna close
mike was like wiping the sweat off he
busted a nut and then they ran out the
door yes basically that happened so good
for you i was like yeah you know of
course i have the keys and so but i
didn't realize that i didn't have the
keys until i got to my car when i'm like
oh [ __ ] i can't get into my car i guess
we're not making it into sushi on time
and then um and you're locked out of the
door yeah and then i'm watching the
outfit so you didn't make it to sushi we
were late i mean it was okay in the end
but uh why didn't you just jump in your
girlfriend's car did she drive she
didn't have her keys were also in the
house
oh
dude because i'm so food oriented i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] about my locked
keys let's [ __ ] get to the food place
so we'll come back and figure all this
[ __ ] out it was like it was just
like is it safe yeah
let's just get food first yeah yeah i
feel like i would have called an uber if
it wasn't already like 9 p.m at night
and so it's like well
either i take care of this now or i go
into my house the next day you know it's
the only thing i'll think about like you
have a one-track mind enough to do that
it's the only thing i'll think about
when i'm sitting there eating sushi i'll
be like am i gonna get my [ __ ] keys
out of this goddamn car
yeah that's like that's me until it's
done i'm gonna be pissed about it but
bart's thinking about food the whole
time the locksmith is like can you hurry
up
i need a [ __ ] hamburger man are you
[ __ ] happy
another restaurant closed another one
closed the dog hurry up
the late filter [ __ ]
what's open dude
hey you know with kovit though those
[ __ ] yelp hours are [ __ ]
sometimes man you'll show up and they're
like we were closed an hour ago and i'm
like well yelp says
too bad when they spit my order back at
me i'm like i will never go to your
[ __ ] establishment again but then i'm
like oh but you're really busy so you
don't need my business
it's a double edged sword yeah i can't
win damn that's so true because i've
tried to order from the habit or some
[ __ ] and they're always like nah [ __ ]
you we're busy
oh that really
drop your order really not not today
like [ __ ] i tried to order from
like tender greens during lunch and then
it was like put it in for now and
usually it's like oh your order is going
to take an hour pick it up in an hour
they were just like nah we don't want
your work it's too busy we don't want
you they were like literally it's like
it's too we're too busy we don't want
you try again later and i'm like what
they can't even just say like make me a
salad and pick it up in two hours how
hard it is
but i'm like they're making that many
salads they're like [ __ ] you
it's been a great start to the nfl
season and it's only been getting better
at draftkings the official daily fantasy
partner of the nfl baby football
draftkings is putting new customers in
the center of the action with a free
shot at millions of dollars and total
prizes oh millions of dollars please i
need it get in on the action now it's
simple just pick up your lineup stay
under the salary cap and see how your
team stacks up against the competition
feel the nfl action like never before
with a shot at millions of dollars in
prizes i just can't get over the
millions man
millions draftkings is safe secure and
reliable i mean come on that nfl is
officially backing this and the best
part is you can deposit and withdraw
your cash whenever you want download the
draftkings app now and use the code off
the record this week new customers can
get a free shot at the millions of total
prizes we've been talking about enter
the code off the record to get a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes oh you keep saying millions like
no that's a lot of money man
[Music]
that's the code off the record only at
draftkings the official partner of the
nfl
minimum five dollar deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details details
there's a worker shortage in everything
now too so now they're just like i don't
want customers there's too many
customers nobody wants to go back to
work every restaurant i've been to there
they always say sorry we're short
staffed the whole world is short stuff
they keep saying that have you seen that
uh a lot of fast food places are doing
sign-in bonuses like you get paid yeah i
saw something they pay you like pretty
damn good too unemployment dude
real nice right now oh man that's a good
deal i might start working at mcdonald's
just for the bonus decision i want the
bonus and i'll quit you know what i
don't understand though and this is this
has nothing to do this is more about
mcdonald's i like mcdonald's but go
ahead and talk [ __ ] dude i'm about to
i'm good to go that's his culture
i go to mcdonald's this is it this is
gonna be a hot take
i'll never understand if you get chicken
nuggets how can the people who work at
mcdonald's forget to give you sauce
that's [ __ ] up yeah like seriously
like if i'm if i'm in the car they
forget yeah it's happened to me so many
times tastes like [ __ ] without sauce oh
ice specified i don't know yeah of
course but like if now you're gonna go
work at mcdonald's right and someone
orders nuggets and you see that they
don't put sauce or they don't specify
i'll punch you you know i'm like the
first thing i think about is is this
person either a psychopath yeah or have
they forgotten their sauce what sauce do
they want oh you are so innocent you're
like you're like i mean i've already
eaten their order and i've murdered the
customer
i've been living half of the employees
are high but even more so you'd be like
yo i love barbecue sauce and sweet and
sour sauce they're like whatever your
choices with nuggets all day it's all i
believe i ordered chick uh i remember i
ordered chicken nuggets one time right
and what i got was a chicken breast
was it fried like a chicken sandwich
chicken breast it happened here i even
have a [ __ ] picture of it on
instagram so what was it one piece of
chicken fried chicken i got the small
like what's the four piece or the six
piece the small box are you sure you
weren't high and went to kfc instead
yeah like is that what happened and i
opened it and it was one white chicken
breast just sitting there it wasn't even
fried it was like a just like it was the
one for the chicken sandwich how long
ago was this what several years ago i
was about to say because i was like they
don't even have grilled chicken breasts
i feel like there was a handful of high
employees that always [ __ ] up orders
but that was the worst one how do you
[ __ ] that up though you know i mean
they're both chicken but still it wasn't
a chicken nugget can we talk about the
delightful feeling that you have when
you get home and you have a bag of
mcdonald's and there's 20-piece chicken
nuggets in there with full sauce it's
pretty good it's really nothing beats it
dude you know it's on dude i will say
their app is pretty good because you can
buy individual sauces which is where
they you know where you have the app oh
yeah hey what's what's the benefits of
getting that because they're always
you're always yelling at me together
coupons so that that's that's wrong
oh yeah i've got all the fast food apps
i recommend everyone at home
of the restaurant just sold me dude
what's the best app the easiest one to
use that's better than postmates or
grubhub or whatever oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah like if you know you're getting
mcdonald's then just get them out yeah
just get the app i live i live near uh
wendy's and mcdonald's i love wendy's i
love wendy's dude we're underrated you
just pre-order it so what i'll do is
i'll pre-order and then i go through the
drive-through
and it's like made right there you just
tell them like hey i'm picking up a
mobile order here's my name and then you
have your order but the advantage is you
can like get really specific
on the order so you don't like tomato
remove the tomato you want to add bacon
add bacon you want double cheese double
cheese like stuff like you just can't do
in person because it's just a pain in
the ass yeah do you feel like an [ __ ]
when you exactly but now it's just you
know the computer just prints the ticket
that's wow that's great you can order
the sauces so you want like 99 barbecue
sauces go for it
because always you know what i always
like yo i need 10 sweet and sour it's
gonna be extra money you know i'm like i
[ __ ] know
i'll give you the two dollars i'm not a
crazy person that's why they do that is
because people throw [ __ ] at them
like you yeah i'm there for the bad
times that's true
there's trauma behind that that's true
the way they're talking about it is like
hey man
the ptsd yeah from the mcflurry in the
face because it used to be free yeah you
remember that
and then the ketchup thing too why are
they so like can i get some ketchup sure
and i give you two packets you're like
come on i got large fries dude i need
like four of them i hear there's a
ketchup package there was there was a
shortage yeah but this is pre-pandemic
though they started doing this earlier
with the sauces they used to give me too
much ketchup packets back there yeah
they used to grab [ __ ] you man nobody
wants to hear it you know what you can
do on the app which is crazy but then
you can save it for next time when you
take it home put it in your fridge oh i
got the bottle in the fridge though you
know that's what it is
has a cheese cheese sauce so you can get
the cheese sauce that they put on their
baked potato for chicken nuggets holy
[ __ ] dude
what else you got bro what else you i
know all the the piggy foods how often
do you eat fast food and how often do
you work out that is the real question
i work out at least three times a week
that's pretty good it's really good at
least i work out more than you and i'm
fatter and i eat way less fast food what
the [ __ ] probably fast food at least
like once a week is that your [ __ ] like
if you could if you could you'd eat it
all the time
if i could
i think now if i ate it all the time i'd
feel like [ __ ] yeah if you asked me 10
years ago i could eat 40 chicken nuggets
every day right the other days or other
meals are they like super on point like
salads and whatever or like yeah like
i'll try to eat one big salad
a day like today i didn't get lunch
today because
like just for calorie count control so
you're kind of fast no no i'm just just
yeah just maintaining your calories your
daily calories how many meals you eat
today
today i'll have two okay so i i had
breakfast good job for breakfast wendy's
i just had eggs they do have breakfast
now so like watch your mouth bro
i had two eggs and uh do you boil them
as well no i had them sunny side up it's
probably because i have cheap months
so that doesn't cheat much there it is
dude i get it i will say this i like i
will only if i'm like oh i need to
really really get in shape i'll only do
it for projects
otherwise like i'm pretty
flexible what if you had a project where
you were fat more wendy's more weddings
i'm not gonna complain if it was the
right you know those roles where you
have to like get really small or really
big yeah have you ever had one where
it's like not like where i had to be
like okay i need to gain 30 pounds or
lose 30 pounds either way but there's
just the slight adjustments yeah so i
try to just be you know normal so that i
can make the jump either way
in either direction now that we have
like the pantry because we have like a
family right so we've got all kinds of
snacks and people come over and family
come over
like i don't know why but
when when you're walking and around
sometimes you're just like i wonder
what's going to happen in the pantry
you don't even know why you're there
but you're like i shouldn't even come
back you're like what do you think
there's a villain
go to the pantry and then i'm like hmm
should i eat anything here dude look at
joe bro he looks perplexed
i understand this because when i go home
the first thing that i always do is like
i wonder what
indian snacks my mom has bought like
they've changed over the last 25 years
this guy's pantry though is a walk-in
closet that's why i'm just like that's a
[ __ ] food storage yeah yeah but then
he goes on the grocery store and like
because the way so the way that geo was
raised her and her brothers and sisters
they always had snacks like the mom is
super hospitable okay so that's what she
brings to like our family
where there's a bunch of little bins and
you could probably find the whole
supermarket there in a small batch so a
little bit of oreos a little bit of
chips ahoy a little bit of kitkats a
little bit or whatever so i go there and
i'm like sounds like a dream i need to
put something in my mouth while i think
so i go kit kats handful of those are
they
are they in tupperware containers that
are like air sealed and labeled i love
it see how i gotta go this is great yes
i know exactly xoxo yeah and then i'm
like oh my god i haven't had honey
graham crackers in a while take like two
of those
and by the time i pick my snack i
probably i probably put down maybe like
600 calories with the snacks before i
end up leaving because you're gonna dude
it's bulking season all day you brought
the [ __ ] buffet to your pantry man
that's dope there's a little bit of
everything in there i love that he's so
food guilty he's like i wonder what's
gonna happen in the pantry
wow
i'm one it's a mystery
you're like man this is not in my
control dude and what's funny is
the snacks are calling you tycho will
hear me in there because he loves
[ __ ] snacks like as all kids do he's
in the living room and he's like papa
what are you doing in there oh my
nothing and i hear his little feet like
is there anything that you can that like
pisses him off oh yeah if like if i'm
eating a snack and i'm not sharing so
sometimes just to [ __ ] around with them
i'll get like i'm not even eating
anything i'll take like a bag of chips
i'm like
mmm
god damn this is so good it was papa
papa i'm like oh that's so good oh my
god it's gone
[Laughter]
you
[Laughter]
now i have a feeling like in that place
where he does his hide and seek he
probably just has a stash of potato
chips from your psychological abuse
[ __ ] he's like he's gonna go high for
two and a half minutes i can crush four
bags of potato chips
didn't one of our friends do like play
hide and seek and they heard him in the
pantry just eating chocolate and [ __ ] oh
yeah he was eating so we got i don't
even know where he got these that was
his hiding spot we got one of those
macadamia nuts like hawaii chocolate
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then this one he
was like probably hide and seek and then
he was in the pantry
and then the lights were off i turned
the lights on and he's holding a blanket
and then i was like there you are goes
you found me and his mouth was full of
chocolate
you found i'm like what are you eating
chocolate you know what you got to start
doing is start putting the sewing kits
in the cookie tins
which is what's like they're just really
[ __ ] with them
because that was i don't know like
that's like a thing i feel like a lot of
immigrant families experience where you
like open up like a food storage and
then you oh it's like something some
food container and you open it up and
it's like something completely else
yours i cuz i do that now but not with
sewing kits because the tins are so good
for storing stuff yeah and so that's
when i was like oh cookie i forgot even
the company but it was like the sugar
cooker like the danish cookies cookies
and you open it it's a full tiny oh
you're like yeah it's like blue and red
and you're like yeah and you're like
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you